well my first guest tonight has lost an
unbelievably large number of relatives
to war in Gaza in 2009 tragedy struck Dr
iseline abues when an Israeli tank
shelled his home claiming the lives of
his three daughters and a
niece but the current conflict has also
taken the lives of many more of his
relatives and Dr abues a trailblazing
figure made history as the First
Palestinian doctor to serve in an
Israeli hospital he's a passionate
advocate for peace and Reconciliation
between Israelis and Palestinians a
mission that he encapsulated in his
Memoir entitled I shall not hate a Gaza
doctor's Journey on the path to peace
and human dignity and I'm I feel honored
actually to say that Dr Isel abues joins
me now doctor thank you for coming here
today thank you thank you so much I I
greatly appreciate it I know we were
just talking before we came on air you
were raised in the jabali refugee I was
born raised and lived and my home still
in jabalia Camp and a lot of your
relatives have already been killed since
October the 7th there yes uh in these
air strikes but also you've told me that
right now there are ongoing attacks yes
they are there in jabalia Camp living
staying there they are alive
now I don't know after we finish if they
will be alive to talk to them or not but
it's important pce I want to tell you
let us talk
a man to a man do you have children yes
so a father to a father a human to human
you
know once the app fell down we discover
the
gravity so let us
today discover the humanity and the
truth because the truth is important
based on evidence Jesus said seek the
truth and the truth sets you free and I
hope all to be free today from this
meeting and to be human and to behave as
a human and to Advocate only and just
only for a Humanity how many members of
your family have been lost since October
the 7th about the
25 October 7th when I watched
it I found that my sister's house where
my brothers and nieces were there and
this is all the members of the family
who were killed
these are all your members of your
family of the family on the
7eventh they became biles their
bodies this is my niece who was killed
this is her
body this my
niece who was engineering
graduated she found she was found under
the
rubel this is my nie is a medical doctor
she was supposed to start her
speciality this my cousin this is my
nephew who is a
physiotherapist and he was
killed this is my niece's
daughter and that's what we want to see
these people they have
names they have faces and that's what is
needed this is my daughter
bisan who was killed 16th of January
2009 who said to meet violence with
violence doesn't solve any problem
there is an alternative way it's not by
action and reaction it's by being a
human and behaving and thinking of
others this is May and aah even my niece
she named her daughter a after my
daughter a was killed
also these daughters I raise them to be
human to be advocate for human I send
them to be scammed
and she said to me with Israelis with
the Israelis and she said to me I found
how similar are we we are similar but we
need to be equal we need to be free we
need to appreciate the dignity the
freedom of all does the life I want to
ask you does the life of the
Palestinians matter as equal to the
Israelis or not yes does the freedom of
the Palestinians
matter as the freedom of the Israelis
yes and that's what always I advocated
for I walked at the hospital when I
deliver a baby the newborn baby The Cry
of the newborn baby is a cry of Hope Cry
of life but now we are crying blood our
tears are
blood the children that I help to
deliver they are free all of them are
free why not to run a normal free life
medicine for me is a human equalizer
stabilizer socializer and harmonizer so
we need to live a free with dignity with
equality in this world and that's the
peace I fully Advocate it because once
we have these means peace will be a
consequence violence that we talk about
violence what is violence violence when
we violate someone's dignity life and
human rights so it's
time and even October 7th approved
because we tried it many times military
means and Wars It's a futile it's a
waste of time and
lives it increases Bloodshed animosity
hatred violence pain suffering and most
important is the extremism the the only
way is to set and I am sure this can't
be solved with the military means it's
only by political and diplomatic means
acknowledging the rights of all to live
side by side as equal and that's the
only way without leaving anyone
behind you talked to earlier about
growing up in the jabali refugee camp
which was struck of caused by air
strikes devastatingly killing member
members of your families you just Rec
counted so powerfully what was life like
when you were there as a young person My
Life as a Palestinian refugee because I
was born as a refugee my parents were
refugees my grandparents were refugees
they were expelled from their Homeland
to be thrown as a refugee and being a
refugee what do we mean by a
refugee you are deprived of your dignity
you become moving in this world naked
exposed but thanks to our parents that
they lost everything but they realize
the hope is in their children we have to
be educated and Palestinian people they
invest everything in the education of
their
children they cut from their food that
now in Gaza Strip with the collective
punishment they are deprived of a bread
of water of health of gas of a fuel how
the world can watch it and not to take
action how can you tolerate to see your
son hungry he needs milk what are you
going to do when I see a bleeding
patient I rush to stop the bleeding when
I see a woman who is a labor pain I rush
to help her without discrimination or to
say to her why are you screaming why are
you crying and that's what we need so as
a child a
was I suffered of romatic fever admitted
to the hospital I wanted to be a medical
doctor in order to rescue my family from
the misery of life and that's we as
Palestinians we don't believe in the
impossible thing we have hope in our
children I succeeded to get a
scholarship to study medicine in Cairo
everything in life I planned I succeeded
from jabalia camp to car University to
London to Italy to Belgium to Harvard
University even when I went to Harvard
the only thing which was
standing with me was palestin flag to be
raised I am Palestinian and the proud
Palestinian and that's what I want the
world to hear from the Palestinians
Palestinians are people like others with
hopes with the plans with the dreams
they love life and they they care about
others and that's what we want the world
to hear from us not to hear about us the
only impossible thing I believe in is to
return my daughters back to life it was
2008 I think when you lost your wife to
cancer and that was a crushing blow and
you were left to bring up your eight
children on your own yes and then within
a year devastatingly an Israeli tank
during that war at the time that was
raging at the time with Gaza an Israeli
tank fired on your house and your three
daughters and the niece were all killed
in the most brutal manner imaginable
blown to Pieces by this tank and you
were there I was with them and there was
an extraordinary moment and I have asked
if if you're comfortable with us to play
a little bit of this because it I
remembered at the time I was at CNN uh
we just about to join CNN I remember uh
hearing this and it was uh just so
moving because you had a friend an
Israeli television station and you had
regular dialogue with him during this
war and you would call in and you'd
update and so on and you came on and you
spoke to him just after you'd lost your
daughters to this strike and this is a
little bit of that
conversation
it's it's one of the most agonizing
things I've ever watched on television
and eventually your friend that
presenter he had to he had to go cuz he
wanted to keep talking to you and he was
so distressed himself he wanted to go
off and do it privately which he did but
an agonizing moment for you for him for
everybody involved in that and as a
consequence of that many people in your
position may have chosen a path of
wanting revenge or retribution in some
way to meet violence with violence but
you went completely a different way and
you ended up taking your family and you
ended up in
Canada how did you find the strength to
not go down the path of wanting Revenge
it's important what you mention because
my wife passed away 16th of September
20084 to 5:00 p.m. and my daughters were
killed 16th of January 2009 quter to 5
p.m. 4 months
exactly two traumas
tragedies and what you heard what I said
Ya Allah y you know the meaning oh god
oh Lord yes at that moment as what I see
now I lost faith in the
humanity because the world was watching
what is happening as we are watching
what is happening now Palestinians are
just numbers they are not numbers they
are human yes and that's what I would
like each of us who are watching to zoom
in to put himself in the position of the
Palestinian you know what you did so
powerfully uh doctor was when you showed
the pictures of your family so but it's
you but you put a name in the to the
face and made people at home watching
this understand but it's important what
helped me I am a person of
Faith this is
important my life experience my
profession as a medical doctor if a
patient dies I don't stay
there I have to move to the next patient
to save but I need to learn why the
first patient died and what are the
causes the triggers of the death of that
patient
[Music]
well I'm still with Dr iseline Abu I'm
sure anyone who watched that uh first
part of his interview uh would have been
like me I think
very I think taken aback by the
eloquence that you talk with the courage
that you speak with it's really palpable
and uh I'm just so glad you came in to
do this with me face to face so I can
really feel it from you because you're
so right
Palestinian lives are as important as
Israeli lives and you know here's the
question I want to ask
you how do we your entire life has been
ravaged by this conflict from when you
were baby to now and you've lost so many
members of your family and you're losing
them as we speak probably horrifically
in this camp that you grew up in it's
like this Vicious Circle That Never Ends
how do we end it yeah we need to end to
understand the root causes of the
problem the Palestinian people and the
Israeli people and I described it we are
like conjoined
twins we have no other way than to live
together and when we speak about peace
and the people they talk about peace
peace is not just a word peace is a way
of life that we believe in it and there
are between whom we want peace peace is
a relationship between me and you even
peace is a relationship between us and
the Earth that we damage the Earth with
the the climate change and there are
certain requirements for peace we need
Justice equality
Freedom human rights right equal rights
human equal rights then peace will be a
consequence of that can peace ever be
achieved now if Hamas are in charge in
Gaza as I mentioned to you it's about
Palestinian people and then Israeli
people it's not about Palestinians and
the settlers this mage or Ben or those
settlers we want peace between the
people and that's what is needed
Palestinians and Israelis we are created
but that has to in the end that has to
be a political solution it's the only
way do but do you think on either side
there is the leadership there that can
possibly Forge peace believe me even if
there is no we need the International
Community to bring them and we have the
platform we have the international
resolutions we have the human rights
resolutions because ending the conflict
all of the world will benefit from it
you see the consequences of what is
happening now the consequences are
spreading everywhere in the world you
see it in UK
polarization the marshes everything so
when we solve the conflict there all of
the world will benefit from why do you
think it's not being solved yet I mean I
look at Northern Ireland for example
which was three decades or more of
violence but eventually it got resolved
but it seems to you know why why I met
with Martin mcginness before and he said
to me we were going confronting each
other once we started to move side by
side as equal we put an end to that and
that's what we need the International
Community the world that we can
Palestinians and Israelis to move side
by side as equal with dignity and
respect of the human rights not as
Fighters because small room can't accom
Two fighters but it can accommodate
hundreds of friends and that's the only
way and we are so close to each other
the communalities between Palestinians
and Israel is more than anyone else so
we need to use it but based as I said on
equality respect of the human rights
Dignity of the Palestinians is equal to
the Dignity of the Israelis the freedom
of the Palestinians even I go far beyond
that the Israelis Freedom safety
security a future and Independence is
linked and dependent on the
Palestinians we are one we are conjoined
the twins we can't separated so it's
time to understand also military means
and power will never put an end to this
do do you obviously you dream of this
but do you think it's a realistic dream
that in your lifetime you can have a
two-state solution with Israel and
Palestine both identifying each other as
States and people living with equal
human rights do you think that's
possible as I said to you nothing is
impossible in life if there is a will
there is a way and that's what is needed
and that's what is needed even if the
Palestinians and the Israelis there is a
challenge we need the involvement of the
International Community Based on Fair
intervention based on the inter because
we want to have order in this world we
want you know this order because you we
live in a discordant World these days so
we want to resume a trust in the
International Community in order the
people in this world they lost safety
security trust so we want to resume it
and that's the only way to start with
the Palestinian Israeli conflict based
on the human rights conventions the
international resolutions and to resume
a trust in the international
institutions believe me I see it yes it
can be quickly if I ask you before yes
arat will meet with Rabin and to shake
hands when year before 94 are you crazy
they will not and they met they were
calling yes arat as a terrorist but then
he became a hero Nelson Mandela yes he
was a terrorist yeah but he was from his
side he was a freedom fighter and that's
what we need we need wisdom we need the
rational people we need the involvement
of the International Community Dr We R
another time on this interview and I
know you want to go and find out what's
happening to your family right now I
would love to stay in touch with you I
would love you to come back on the show
regularly and we talk about this because
you're such a powerful voice thank you
for you so much and my heart goes out to
you for what's happened to your it
really does for all the family members
youve thank you for all of the
Palestinians and the Israelis yes you
are an amazing voice thank you thank you
very much indeed thank you a remarkable
man Dr iseline Abu